Bueno, acabo de encontrar un
canal de YouTube sin rostro que fue creado hace apenas 2
meses.  El objetivo de este vídeo
era comprobar si podía recrear este
canal utilizando inteligencia artificial.  Ahora bien, si quieres
aprender a usar la IA y la
automatización mediante IA para crear un
canal de YouTube como este y comenzar tu
andadura en YouTube, en este vídeo te
voy a mostrar básicamente todo.
Así que, si quieres aprender, este vídeo es
para ti.  Así que, comencemos.  Ahora, una vez que
hayas instalado Cloud Code en tu
ordenador, abre Cloud Code de esta manera
.  Como puedes ver, esto es
Cloud Code en un ordenador.  Y lo que tienes que
hacer es hacer clic aquí arriba a la
izquierda en código.  Asegúrate de no estar en el espacio de
trabajo compartido, no estar en el chat, debes
estar programando.  Ahora bien, para
poder automatizar la creación de estos
vídeos, necesitamos instalar la
habilidad de Hicksfield.  Para ello, quiero que
vuelvas a tu navegador y busques
Hicksfield aquí.  Ve a
Hicksfield y crea una cuenta.  Una vez que
hayas creado una cuenta en Hicksfield,
quiero que hagas clic aquí donde
dice MCP y CLI.  Una vez que haga clic
aquí, asegúrese de hacer clic en CLI
aquí.  Luego, lo que quiero que hagas es
copiar este primer comando aquí simplemente
haciendo clic en él.  Luego, en la
barra de búsqueda de su computadora, escriba
terminal, haga clic en
él y luego pegue este comando
aquí y presione enter.  Una vez que pulses Enter, se
instalará la interfaz de línea de comandos (CLI).  Luego, lo que
quiero que hagas es volver a
Hicksfield, copiar el segundo comando de
aquí, copiarlo, volver a tu terminal,
pegar el segundo comando y presionar
enter.  Te pedirá que
autorices el acceso a Hicksfield con tu
ordenador.  Básicamente, necesitas una
cuenta en Hicksfield.  Luego, tienes que
volver a Hicksfield y copiar este último
comando aquí, que instalará
la habilidad de Hicksfield, que nos ayudará a
generar estas imágenes.  Entonces, copia este
comando, regresa a tu terminal, pega
el comando, presiona enter e instala
la habilidad.  Es así de simple.  Ahora bien,
no voy a pulsar Enter porque
ya he instalado esas cosas, y en
realidad es bastante sencillo.  Como puedes ver,
solo tienes que copiarlos, pegarlos, pulsar enter,
pulsar enter, pulsar enter, y listo.
Ahora, una vez que tengas todo eso
instalado, podemos empezar a crear los
vídeos.  Ahora, déjame mostrarte cómo hacerlo
.  Ahora, lo que necesitas es el
guion de YouTube.  Ahora bien, dependiendo del tipo de
vídeos que quieras hacer, tal vez no
quieras hablar de humanos primitivos,
tal vez quieras hablar del espacio, o
tal vez quieras hablar de extraterrestres, o
tal vez quieras hablar de animales.
Dependiendo de tu nicho de mercado, necesitas un
guion.  Necesitas crear un guion para
el vídeo.  Ahora, lo que quiero que hagas es
copiar esta indicación aquí.  Déjame
mostrarte la consigna.
Este es el mensaje principal que vamos a
utilizar.  Como puedes ver, el
mensaje dice: "Vas a generar
imágenes para un script de YouTube, una imagen
por cada marca de tiempo del script".  Esta
es la parte más importante,
que dice: "Una imagen por cada
marca de tiempo en el guion".  Aquí
dice: "Tu trabajo consiste en leer el guion
con atención y crear una imagen independiente
para cada marca de tiempo. Si el guion tiene
marcas de tiempo como 0 segundos, 3 segundos, 7
segundos, 10 segundos, 12 segundos, 20
segundos, entonces debes generar una
imagen para cada una de esas marcas de tiempo".
Esta es la parte más importante de la
consigna, ¿verdad?  Porque esto es lo que
nos va a ayudar a automatizar el proceso de
creación de estos vídeos.  Luego, aquí,
dice los requisitos de estilo, y
dice que la imagen debe parecer un
dibujo extremadamente simple para principiantes hecho
en MS Paint.  Debería parecer que alguien
que no es bueno dibujando lo hizo
rápidamente a mano, ¿verdad?  Esta parte de la
consigna también es súper importante porque le está
diciendo a Higgs Field cómo
debería verse la imagen, ¿verdad?  Y aquí
tenemos fondo blanco, bla bla bla bla
bla, sin 3D, sin cinemática, bla bla
bla.  Este es el enunciado completo.
Lo que quiero que hagas es escribir una consigna
como esta, o pedirle a ChatGPT o a Claude que te
escriban una consigna como esta.  Y
después de escribir esta indicación, quiero que la
copies
y la pegues en el código de Claude.  Así que,
vuelve al código de Claude y
pega esta indicación en el cuadro de mensaje.
A continuación, quiero que copies el
script con las marcas de tiempo y lo pegues
debajo de esta indicación.  Ahora, todo lo que tienes que
hacer es enviar este mensaje al código de Claude.
Como puedes ver, el código de Claude va a
ejecutar la habilidad aquí, y esta es la
habilidad Campo de Higgs.  Luego, te
pedirá que permitas el acceso a la terminal
varias veces.  Solo tienes que hacer clic en "Permitir"
y, una vez que esté listo, el código de Claude
comenzará a generar las imágenes.  Como
pueden ver aquí, la habilidad
Higgs Field se está ejecutando y está
generando las imágenes.  Como puedes ver,
me está pidiendo que le dé acceso.  No
creo que puedas verlo.  Déjame... Sí,
en realidad no puedes verlo debido a mi
cámara web, así que voy a usar mi cámara web.
Como pueden ver aquí, pueden permitirlo una sola vez
o permitirlo siempre.  Haz clic en "Permitir siempre".   ¿
Bien?  Como pueden ver, ahora generaré
38 imágenes.  Ahora, solo
generará 38 imágenes porque he copiado
solo una pequeña parte del script.  Si
copias el script completo,
te generará más de 100 imágenes, lo cual
es una auténtica locura.
Básicamente vas a tener imágenes para tu
video cada pocos segundos.  Y este
proceso de aquí te lleva literalmente unos
10 minutos.  Y básicamente, así es como se
ve.  Como pueden ver aquí,
está generando las imágenes por lotes
y lo está haciendo bastante rápido.  Ahora, para
comprobar tus imágenes, solo tienes que
volver a tu cuenta de Higgs Field.  Así que,
volviendo al campo Higgs, como
pueden ver, todo lo que tienen que hacer es hacer clic
aquí arriba a la izquierda donde dice
imagen.  Haz clic aquí y, aquí mismo,
deberías ver todas las imágenes que se están
generando en este momento.  Como pueden
ver, si me desplazo hacia abajo, tenemos todas las
imágenes del guion.  Y tienen
exactamente el mismo estilo que ese canal.  Entonces,
si volvemos a este canal, y si hago
clic en un video, déjenme silenciarlo.
Tengo YouTube Premium.  No tengo ni idea de por qué
estoy recibiendo anuncios.  Así que YouTube es un
poco astuto.
Como pueden ver, así es como
se ven los videos.  Estas son, literalmente, imágenes de
dibujos malos.  Pero el secreto es que hay
muchísimas imágenes.  Como pueden ver,
las imágenes cambian casi cada 2
segundos, casi cada 3 segundos.  Ese es
el secreto.  Ahora bien, si nos fijamos en las
visualizaciones, vemos que el vídeo se
subió literalmente el 16 de abril de 2026.
Tiene casi 1 millón de visualizaciones, 26.000
me gusta, casi 3.000 comentarios, y la gente
realmente está disfrutando de los vídeos.  Y
puedo desplazarme por el vídeo y
mostrarte que todas las imágenes son idénticas.
Es exactamente el mismo estilo que estamos
generando usando Cloud Code y Higgs
Field.  Si volvemos al campo de Higgs,
veremos que nuestras imágenes son exactamente
iguales.  Aquí tenemos esta imagen.   ¿
Qué más tenemos?  Tenemos estas imágenes
aquí, ¿verdad?  Y lo mejor de todo es
que todas estas imágenes encajan perfectamente con
el guion, ya que cada imagen se
generó para una marca de tiempo específica del
mismo.  Ahora, déjame mostrarte cómo
puedes editar estas imágenes súper rápido.
Entonces, lo que tienes que hacer es volver a
Claude Code aquí, y voy a
detener el proceso de generación de estas
imágenes.  Y básicamente, lo que tienes que
escribir es enlazarme la carpeta con las
imágenes, ¿de acuerdo?  Y
te enlazará con la carpeta donde se crearon y almacenaron todas estas imágenes
.  Ahora bien, si
recibe este mensaje que dice que las
imágenes se generan en Hexfield, se alojan
en línea y no se guardan localmente, puede
pedirle que haga lo siguiente.  Por favor, descargue
estas imágenes localmente y ajuste sus
títulos para que coincidan con la marca de tiempo.  Entonces, si una
imagen se creó en cero 0.00
segundos, ese es el título de la imagen.
Si una imagen se creó para 0:20,
ese es el título de la imagen.  Esto es
sumamente importante porque tener las
marcas de tiempo como título de la imagen es
lo que nos ayudará a crear estos
videos súper rápido, ya que sabremos
exactamente dónde colocarlas para
sincronizarlas con la voz en off.  Así que, envía este
mensaje a Claude y, como puedes ver,
se creará una carpeta para nosotros,
lo cual es genial.  Solo tienes que hacer clic en
permitir y luego descargará
todas las imágenes por ti, lo que de nuevo
automatiza el trabajo y te ahorra mucho
tiempo porque incluso si tienes que
descargar cada imagen, tienes que ir haciendo
clic y descargando, haciendo clic en descargar.  No
solo eso, sino que tampoco tienen los
títulos correctos, y va a ser difícil
editarlos.  De esta forma, Claude Code
descarga todas las imágenes, pero también
cambia sus títulos para que coincidan con las
marcas de tiempo.  Y la razón por la que eso es importante es
porque sabemos dónde colocarlos en
la línea de tiempo cuando editamos el vídeo.
Básicamente, se creará una
carpeta como esta de aquí y, como
puedes ver, dentro de la carpeta, todas las
imágenes comenzarán a
descargarse lentamente.  Como pueden ver, esta es la
primera imagen, ahora la segunda.  En
resumen, editar el vídeo ahora
es muy sencillo.  Abre
tu programa de edición de vídeo aquí,
y si le doy a reproducir, podrás escuchar la
narración.
Imagínate despertarte a las 2:00 de la madrugada y no
[ __ ] el móvil.
Sin brillo, sin notificaciones, sin
notificaciones, sin reloj.
Oscuridad absoluta.
Entonces, y ahora, básicamente, basándonos en el título
de la imagen, este de aquí es 0
segundos, lo sumamos hasta llegar a 7 segundos
aquí.  Porque la siguiente imagen debería
comenzar a los 7 segundos.  Como puede ver,
la segunda imagen muestra 0,07, que son 7
segundos.  La tercera imagen comienza a los
0,15 segundos.  Eso significa que tenemos que arrastrar
la segunda imagen hasta los 15 segundos
aquí.  Podemos ver desde aquí.  Luego vamos
a arrastrar la tercera imagen, ¿y cuándo
va a aparecer la cuarta imagen?
Aparecerá a los 23 segundos.  Así que
vamos a arrastrar esta imagen hasta los 20
3 segundos.  Así.  Luego agregamos
la siguiente imagen y la vamos a arrastrar
hasta los 29 segundos porque la siguiente
imagen aparecerá a los 29 segundos.
Y básicamente, editar el vídeo de esta manera
te va a llevar literalmente 10
minutos.  Como si fuera súper fácil.  La IA está
haciendo la mayor parte del trabajo.  Ahora, si le doy a
reproducir, notarán cómo la voz en off
se sincroniza con cada imagen sin que yo tenga que
escucharla ni pasar
horas pensando y editando.  Imagínate
despertarte a las 2:00 de la madrugada y no [ __ ] el
móvil.  Oscuridad absoluta.
Escuchas
durante 300.000
años.
Bien.  Así es como se pueden crear
estos vídeos mediante la automatización con IA.
Si tienes problemas para crecer en YouTube,
si tus vídeos obtienen cero visualizaciones, 50
visualizaciones, 200 visualizaciones o no logran
superar las 1000 visualizaciones, quizás quieras
ver este vídeo, porque
en él explico por qué algunos
canales se sienten bloqueados en la sombra.  ¿Por qué algunos de
ustedes piensan que YouTube les está aplicando un bloqueo silencioso
y, literalmente, ignorando su canal?  Así que
si quieres aprender sobre el algoritmo
y cómo escapar de él, quizás quieras
ver este vídeo de aquí.